so we covered this story on the Rubin
report today but I thought it warranted
a little extra time you probably heard
about this already in the UK they are
banning certain types of porn from being
produced in the UK not that you can't
watch it in the UK you still if you can
get access to this stuff online or you
can get a DVD from Germany or Japan or
the United States or Mexico or wherever
it is you can still watch this stuff in
the UK but they don't want to actually
produce it here produce it there this
involves stuff like water sports and
certain types of talking dirty and
caning which apparently is smacking
someone with a cane water sport I mom a
lot of this weird I don't want to say
weird it's a lot of the stuff that
people watch it's just what it is we all
have our own little kinks everyone likes
what they like whatever it is what I
thought was interesting about this is
now I don't live in the UK but this sort
of reminds me of a little bit more of
the way the United States was even like
10 or 15 years ago and we sort of had
this moral majority or I guess this is
sort of a little bit after the Clinton
time where the Quinn the Christian right
and then Bush sort of came in and there
was this sort of feeling of this we
needed this moral underpinning and I
think it's really it's really bizarre
because it doesn't really matter as long
as what you do in the privacy of your
home is legal is you know the would the
porn that you watching legal it's not
underage it's not animals I'm pretty
sure that that's mostly illegal I think
in Sweden we did a story that's legal
now or maybe they just made it illegal
I'm not sure but the point is as long as
you do stuff as that is that is legal
what you do in the privacy of our home
is is for your own viewing pleasure and
the thing that I also think is
interesting is that it's like we're
gonna snot stop you from doing it but
we're just not gonna make it here like
you can get it from those other dirty
dirty countries I don't know something
that just seems a little a little off to
me about it because everybody watches
whatever they watch and who cares like
what are they trying to do here if
anything I think that maybe all they're
really accomplishing is that they're
gonna harm the local UK porn economy we
have an example of this right here in
California where in LA they banned porn
without condoms but then all that
happens is if people want to see porn
without condoms well then those porn
companies have to move elsewhere so then
you hurt the local businesses that you
know the guy the porn guy has to get
coffee to you know yeah the porn guy he
likes to get a bagel then he
do that anyway I think it's really
interesting and let people just watch
what they want to watch who cares
England come on we love you England
what's the problem here